FELIPE HOFFA: Hello.
I'm Felipe Hoffa, and today
I am in Melbourne, Australia
to meet my good friends
at Shine Solutions.
With [INAUDIBLE],, we've
done many challenges
like processing 30 terabytes
of data with BigQuery,
or running Hadoop jobs while in
the train, thanks to Dataflow.
But today, we want
to see how much data
we can process with Dataflow
before reaching the city.
Follow me.
I'm here with Graham Polley
from Shine Solutions.
I'm so glad to see you again.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
It's been a while.
Two years.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's been a while.
I remember we did
the 30 terabyte
challenge with BigQuery.
Then you recorded all this
data while with Dataproc while
on the train.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Yeah, in 17 minutes,
we spun up with Dataproc
cluster, Hadoop Spark,
and did it in the 17
minutes on the train.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And today, we're going to
jump from Hadoop to Dataflow.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Dataflow, right.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
GRAHAM POLLEY: We're
going to read lots of data
and try and get the
cluster up and running
and the pipeline finished
by the time we hit the city.
FELIPE HOFFA: That
is pretty cool.
But by the way, you've been
doing a lot of great stuff
other than these challenges.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, a lot's
happened in the last two years
since we've seen each other.
So I'm an official Google
Developer Expert now, GDE.
FELIPE HOFFA: Congratulations.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Thank you very much,
for Google Cloud Platform.
And the only one in Australia.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: It's been cool.
It's an honor.
And we've got the new
Sydney region there,
for Google Cloud Platform
So we're-- that's super news
for us.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
The latency has
gone down by a lot.
GRAHAM POLLEY: It's like 10
milliseconds the last time
I checked the DCP [INAUDIBLE].
And also, Shine
have a new office up
in Sydney, which is cool.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, so we're
in Melbourne and Sydney.
FELIPE HOFFA: I should
check that one out.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: So let's
go toward [INAUDIBLE]
and then we will
discuss all what you're
doing with your customers.
GRAHAM POLLEY: OK.
So we're going to run a simple
pipeline while on the tram,
before we hit the
city, and hopefully it
will be completed by that time.
FELIPE HOFFA: We are
pretty close to the city.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Right.
So I better kick it off.
I'm going to kick it off with
my development environment
so we can have a look at the
code as well, how it's working.
But I'm going to get it started.
FELIPE HOFFA: Perfect.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
this pipeline is
going to read 10.6 billion
records from Google Cloud
Storage.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: It's
going to run them
through a
transformation, a ParDo,
and then it's going to write
the results, the BigQuery,
for further analysis.
So it somewhat simulates
what we do in production
for our customers.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
How many files is this?
GRAHAM POLLEY: It's
a few thousand.
FELIPE HOFFA: A few thousand
files containing 10 million--
10.6 million [INAUDIBLE]?
GRAHAM POLLEY: It's
about half the terabyte.
Yeah, so the beauty
of this is I only
have to write about
20 lines of code.
And using the Java SDK-- there
are other SDKs for Dataflow
as well.
You have the Python one.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah?
GRAHAM POLLEY: I chose data.
I wrote 20 lines of code,
but all the infrastructure
spun up for me.
I don't care about any
of the infrastructure.
You guys worry about that stuff.
I don't have to worry that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, you
have 20 lines of codes.
You are telling Dataflow
to first read the files.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: Then--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Transform it.
So I'm looking for a
certain word in each title.
So the data that we're using
is a sample from Wikipedia,
and so it's got all the
page views for Wikipedia.
FELIPE HOFFA: This is whatever
logic you want to run.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And I'm looking
for Melbourne at a time,
because we're in
beautiful Melbouren.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And then we'll, at the end--
GRAHAM POLLEY: We do
a write to BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: Write to BigQuery.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: A strange write?
GRAHAM POLLEY: No,
not a strange write.
So while I was
running my tests, I
found out doing a
strange write to BigQuery
was taking a little bit
longer than I had hoped.
And the reason was Dataflow
was producing a lot of files
that BigQuery then
subsequently has to do a load
job in each of those files in.
So what I do is I
do a little trick.
I specify without
charting, and I write back
to GCS a single file,
and then load that
in using the BigQuery API.
A little pro tip.
FELIPE HOFFA: And how is
your deployment going?
GRAHAM POLLEY: OK.
Let's have a look.
So we can see from the
Java logs that the workers
have started successfully.
So probably the next
thing we want to do
is flick over to Google
Cloud Platform console
and have a look at
the Dataflow platform.
FELIPE HOFFA: So who is
monitoring all of your--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Everything.
The beauty of this is that it
allows me to focus on the code.
I don't have to worry about
any of the infrastructure.
So it's like hands
off, great, it
lets us do what we want to do.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's good.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So if we go
to the Google Cloud Platform
and we jump over to Dataflow.
Fingers crossed, we're tethering
off my phone, remember.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
GRAHAM POLLEY: We're not
using any type of problem.
FELIPE HOFFA: We're doing
this well on the tram.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
So I'm tethering my
phone, which is in my bag,
and we're spitting up a
massive cluster of Google Cloud
Platform.
FELIPE HOFFA: So now we
are running Dataflow here.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
So the pipeline is spun up.
It's Actually spun up--
I think it's spun up to
50 VMs or 35 VMs, which
Dataflow did itself.
It looked at the amount of
data that it had to read
and went, oh, I need more
VMs in the stack, started
bringing them in.
And you can see it's
autoscaling now.
FELIPE HOFFA: Able
to [INAUDIBLE]----
how many records
are we processing?
GRAHAM POLLEY: This is crazy.
On 4G network, it's
spinning all this up.
We're processing 27
million records a second.
FELIPE HOFFA: A second.
GRAHAM POLLEY: A second.
FELIPE HOFFA: We'd
better hurry up.
We're getting close to the city.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Where are we now?
Shrine of Remembrance.
So we're pretty close.
We've better get cracking.
FELIPE HOFFA: It is some
city highlights, too.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
of course, when
we deploy this
for our customers,
we don't run it from our
development environments,
obviously, so we have a proper
deployment process for now.
And we use Cloud functions
for all that stuff.
We're doing good.
FELIPE HOFFA: OK, so
what kind of stuff
are you doing for
your customers?
GRAHAM POLLEY: So
with our customers,
this is a very basic pipeline
that I'm showing today.
It's just the basic read,
transform, and write.
But for our customers, we apply
a lot more complex business
logic and rules to the pipeline,
so we have multiple side inputs
coming in for our
Dataflow pipeline
from disparate data
sources, transforming it
and then multiple writes out to
BigQuery for further analysis
by the product teams.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: And I can
show you some examples.
FELIPE HOFFA: I would
love to see one.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, I've
got some graph examples.
So this is a really
good example of one
of our public in production.
This is a massive read from GCS.
I think this is maybe
100 files, reading
about 100 million records.
FELIPE HOFFA: These
are real life files.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
right, sitting in GCS.
But the beauty of this is
look at all these side inputs
coming in and
enriching the data,
applying business rules,
logic, transforming that data,
and then writing to multiple
destinations in BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And you're reading this from
a huge file in Google Cloud
Storage, enriching it
with BigQuery tables?
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Actually, this one
is reading from multiple
files in Google Cloud Storage
and then writing
to multiple tables.
But I have an example of another
one which is one big file read.
You can see here.
So this is a massive read
from GCS, a transform,
and then, I don't know,
20 outputs to BigQuery.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
How did you launch
this processes?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Not from my
development environment.
FELIPE HOFFA: It's not you
clicking can run every day.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So we've
got a pretty nice pattern
that we use in production and
our customers like it as well.
So what we do is we
set up a Google Cloud
Function, listening
to a [INAUDIBLE],,
and when a new file arrives,
that kicks the Cloud Function
off which cause a Dataflow
template which then
starts processing the data.
And that's the trick, to
run the Dataflow pipeline
as a template.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
You set up all your code
as a Dataflow template--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct, yeah.
FELIPE HOFFA: --that then, you
can trigger from a Google Cloud
Function with whatever is
in your file to be read.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
So it's all hands off.
We don't maintain
any of that stuff.
It's servlets.
It's all the way through.
FELIPE HOFFA: Servlets.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah.
I had to get the
buzz word in, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
How many records have
we processed so far?
GRAHAM POLLEY: 8.6 billion.
FELIPE HOFFA: 8.6
billion so far?
OK, so let's go back
to the customers,
because it's really
interesting to see
how everything is autoscaling.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Bit of sun
catching your eye, there.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So if
you can jump over here,
we can actually see
the autoscaling history
on the pipelines, right?
So that looks quite nice,
so clusters starting up,
more VMs coming into the
stack to process the data.
The flows is detecting
that there's not
so much data to process
anymore and starts
dropping VMs in the
stack, which saves
our clients a lot of money.
FELIPE HOFFA: Is that right?
Because they're
paying by server.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah, correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: And this one
jumped all the way back
to 20 servers at the beginning?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Zero, 20,
and then went back down
to 10, and back up to 20
again, and then, eventually,
the whole cluster was torn up.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's great.
So less servers are
needed in some steps--
GRAHAM POLLEY: Correct.
FELIPE HOFFA: --as
autoscaling goes down.
GRAHAM POLLEY: But we don't
determine those steps.
Dataflow does all that
for us with autoscaling.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So even
if we go back here,
we can see all the pipelines
that have run in production.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, so these
are running permanently,
like many times a day, all
thanks to Cloud Functions?
GRAHAM POLLEY:
Yeah, all triggering
from Cloud Functions.
FELIPE HOFFA: And then
you have the templates.
GRAHAM POLLEY: That's right.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: How close
are we to the city?
We'd better do a check--
oh, we're at Fed Square, OK.
So we'd better
check our pipeline.
So how are we doing?
OK.
Almost there.
FELIPE HOFFA: Almost there?
Running--
GRAHAM POLLEY: We're up
to 9 billion records now.
FELIPE HOFFA: Excellent.
GRAHAM POLLEY: 567 gig.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So we've got
to just wait one more minute,
I would say, and then
we'll hit the city,
and hopefully the pipeline
will be finished by then.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
hopefully-- perfect.
Any other tips that
you have for people
doing stuff with Dataflow?
GRAHAM POLLEY: The great
thing about Dataflow
is it allows you to
concentrate on the code itself,
rather than worry about
any of the infrastructure.
The beauty of
Dataflow, as well, it
runs at both batch
and streaming mode.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
GRAHAM POLLEY: So you
write once, but run it
in batch and streaming.
It's really helpful.
So if you've got
streaming realtime data,
you can also use
Dataflow, which is great.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah, we
did this with batch,
but you're also using it for--
GRAHAM POLLEY: For
streaming as well, yeah.
And we do a lot of BigQuery
streaming on top of that,
and we mix the tools together
to solve the problems
that we need to solve.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice.
And you also need
to decide sometimes,
do you use BigQuery or
do you use Dataflow?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Yeah,
so it's picking
the best tool for the job.
Right?
So BigQuery's great at smashing
true data and aggregating it,
and Dataflow is really good
for pulling all that data in,
transforming it, and
sending it to BigQuery
for further analysis.
FELIPE HOFFA: Nice, and
how are we doing here?
GRAHAM POLLEY: We're done.
FELIPE HOFFA: We're done.
Excellent.
Time for a pint.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Definitely.
FELIPE HOFFA: Awesome.
So we made it back to the
Shine offices on time.
Challenge completed.
GRAHAM POLLEY:
FELIPE HOFFA: That
was pretty nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: That
was a great challenge.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
How much data you process, then?
GRAHAM POLLEY: We processed
over 10 billion records that
were in GCS, about 500
gigabytes, almost half
a terabyte, all in under 10
minutes using Cloud Dataflow.
FELIPE HOFFA: In under 10
minutes, 10 billion records?
That's like--
GRAHAM POLLEY: 29
million records a second
being read and
transformed in parallel.
FELIPE HOFFA: While
we were tethering?
GRAHAM POLLEY: While we were
tethering off my mobile phone.
FELIPE HOFFA:
That's pretty cool.
Who handled all the complexity?
GRAHAM POLLEY: Well,
the beauty of it
is Dataflow handled all the
complexity of it, right?
So it spun up the
worker pool, autoscaled
VMs, we went up to 50 VMs,
and then when it was finished,
tore the whole cluster down.
FELIPE HOFFA: That
was pretty nice.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Very nice.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So what do we do now?
GRAHAM POLLEY: That's
a tough question.
Drink a beer?
FELIPE HOFFA: OK.
Salud.
GRAHAM POLLEY: Salud.
Prost.